buongiorno a tutti e grazie nicolò
perché sono qui bella domanda qualche
settimana fa mi scrive nicolò e mi
chiede vuoi partecipare alte dix ma
proprio io siete sicuri si si proprio tu
panico faccio l'errore di chiedere quali
sono gli altri speaker allora inizia a
fare l'elenco campioni olimpici
progettisti della città del futuro
insegnanti che insegnano materie e
progettisti per razzi spaziali doppio
panico e allora per farmi coraggio mi
dice no ma tanto nella tranquilla pensa
a un contenuto che possa essere d'aiuto
alle persone pensa a qualcosa che possa
essere di ispirazione alle altre persone
che sono presenti allora penso
nell'ordine trasformazione digitale è un
tema anche che conosco lo siamo portati
in azienda però c'è gente molto più
esperta di meno
sostenibilità transizione green anche
questo un tema a cui tengo molto però ci
sono persone molto più esperti di me
a un certo punto l'illuminazione come
gestire un'azienda metalmeccanica
partendo da zero ed essendo la figlia
del capo ok di questo ne so abbastanza
posso parlare di questo
e quindi visto che il tema era spazi la
storia che sto per raccontarvi parla
proprio di questo parla del concetto di
dare spazio parla di persone che
ispirano altre persone che danno loro
spazio offrendo opportunità e offrendo
sfide parla di spazi vuoti da riempire e
dell'opportunità di reinventarli e poi
parla di spazi nuovi da creare ma
soprattutto parla dell'importanza di
restituire il favore
per me è facile raccontare questa storia
oggi perché
perché è la storia e la mia storia
personale
comincio col dire che lo sport è stata
una cosa importantissima e che l'ambito
sportivo per un periodo è stato il mio
mondo
ho iniziato giovanissimo a giocando a
pallavolo e e poi ho avuto la fortuna
alle superiori di avere un insegnante di
educazione fisica che mi ha molto
spronata molto ispirata e in quella fase
della mia vita è stata determinante
infatti poi io ho scelto di seguire le
sue orme
e poi mi ha offerto un'opportunità uno
spazio ho iniziato a lavorare nella sua
palestra e ho iniziato a muovere i primi
passi quindi durante la settimana
lavoravo i vari centri sportivi e
palestra nei weekend erano dedicati alla
formazione investivo tutto quello che
guadagnavo informazione perché comunque
avevo comunque sempre un senso diciamo
di non essere all'altezza della
situazione di dover imparare
a un certo punto diciamo avevo comunque
un curriculum molto attrattivo perché
per la mia età insomma ho ricevuto
diverse richieste di lavoro ma c'erano
dei ma diciamo quello che avevo sempre
desiderato fare il mio sogno che che mi
ero immaginata alla fine mi risultava
uno spazio un po stretto perché non
avevo una visione non c'erano problemi
da risolvere
sostanzialmente ho avuto l'opportunità
di frequentare l'azienda di mio papà per
battere la tesi poi mi aveva chiesto
aiuto per una fiera all'estero con
l'inglese quindi hanno iniziato a
frequentare l'azienda che dire fu una
scoperta un sacco di problemi da
risolvere ma perché fosse un'azienda
organizzata male gestita male ma perché
era una piccola realtà dove c'erano un
sacco di cose da fare e dove una persona
in più fa la differenza all'interno del
team e dove mio padre era sovraccaricato
di mille responsabilità e non riusciva
spesso star dietro a tutto
allora se da una parte la passione per
l'ambito sportivo calava dall'altra
parte aumentava l'attrazione per il
mondo dell'impresa e quindi avevo una
sfida enorme davanti a mare perché era
quella di creare un futuro per una da
oltre il suo fondatore che tra l'altro
da tutti era considerato un genio e
oltre a questo c'erano anche degli altri
ostacoli tipo che ero la figlia del capo
poi chiaro l'ultimo arrivato e poi che
era una donna in un contesto che era
molto molto maschile
mi.c tra l'altro una un'altra cosa un
altra diciamo un altro vuoto che
percepivo era quello delle mie
competenze ancora di più rispetto a
prima
provavo proprio diciamo una profonda
inadeguatezza perché non avevo il titolo
di studio il background e quindi diciamo
durante la settimana mi buttavo a
capofitto nel cercare di capire i
processi cosa facevano le persone i
problemi dell'impresa è di nuovo nei
week end dedicati alla formazione per
crescere per arricchire un po il mio
bagaglio di competenze e
diciamo che vivere al massimo le aziende
la formazione poi a un certo punto
sentito la necessità di avere nuovi
stimoli e ho iniziato a collaborare con
un gruppo di imprenditori all'interno
dell'associazione degli industriali ad
alcune iniziative con dei colleghi
metalmeccanici
a un certo punto si crea uno spazio per
me fu scelta come presidente del gruppo
metalmeccanico all'epoca in associazione
alla il gruppo più grande oltre 700
aziende associate di quel gruppo per me
all'epoca era una sfida grandissima però
è stata un'opportunità di di
apprendimento che mi è servita
tantissimo perché ho conosciuto un sacco
di imprenditori dai quali ho imparato
tanto sto imparando tanto ancora oggi
per questo devo ringraziare il mio
collega giorgio per avermi dato spazio e
fiducia
e poi la presidente di allora era una
donna maria cristina ecco sta accanto a
lei che poi ero suo vice presidente e
vederla isart esercitare il ruolo di
presidente quindi una forte leadership
femminile in quel ruolo è stata
un'esperienza che mi ha dato tantissimo
ma adesso la smetto di annoiarvi con con
la storia della mia vita e arriviamo al
punto uno dei temi più dibattuti con i
miei colleghi imprenditori in questo
periodo è
la difficoltà nel trovare personale da
assumere in azienda quindi la mancanza
di competenze e è una specie di vuoto
che si è creato e che nessuno vuole più
riempire c'è il fenomeno della fuga dei
cervelli ragazzi studiano poi mandano un
curriculum vanno all'estero e non
tornano più e poi c'è il grande fenomeno
delle dimissioni di massa considerate
che nel trevigiano dove c'è la mia
azienda
l'anno scorso oltre 36 mila persone
hanno lasciato il lavoro la maggior
parte di questi aveva un contratto a
tempo indeterminato
e poi come se non bastasse crollo delle
nascite quindi 2021 crollo delle nascite
e questa la dice lunga sulla fiducia che
hanno le persone nel futuro ma perché mi
chiedo io perché perché strano questi
spazi vuoti perché le persone vanno
all'estero e poi non tornano lasciano un
lavoro e non fanno più figli
beh la risposta che mi sono data e tra
l'altro questa idea questa idea non
coincide con l'idea del made in italy
che abbiamo all'estero perché anche ad
esempio non solo nel food oppure nella
moda è ma anche ad esempio nei
macchinari industriali ad elevato
contenuto tecnologico se voi chiedete a
una persona che vive all'estero quali
sono i macchinari industriali più
affidabile più innovativi questo vi
risponderà quelli italiani quindi
perché riusciamo ad essere attrattivi
perché non riusciamo a vendere in
qualche modo la nostra mafia bell'idea
che mi sono fatta è che dobbiamo dare
spazio a nuove idee dobbiamo
reinventarci e dobbiamo rendere nota
quella che è la missione dell'azienda a
quella che alla sfida a quelli che sono
i valori e dobbiamo in qualche modo
essere attrattivi non soltanto per i
clienti e per vendere i prodotti ma
anche per attrarre persone che entrano a
far parte della nostra community primi
tra tutti i nostri collaboratori ma
anche i patner i fornitori le comunità
scientifiche le comunità sociali il
territorio
ma allora immagino che adesso voi stiate
pensando ma ok antonella ottimo ma tu
che cosa proponi va io penso che la
formazione sia sia un tema di
attrattività importantissimo penso che
le aziende devono stare vicinissime e a
stretto contatto con le scuole perché
conoscere i docenti conoscere i
professori conoscere diciamo il mondo
scolastico
permette di facilitare l'ingresso dei
ragazzi nelle aziende e quindi avere
diciamo le porte aperte per i ragazzi
che vengono in azienda in stage per
favorire quelli che sono i percorsi di
alternanza nell'ottica di accelerare
questo percorso dalla scuola all'azienda
e di far vedere in realtà come sono le
nostre aziende e
questo poi una volta che i ragazzi sono
entrati in azienda dovremo proporre a
loro delle sfide dovremo in qualche modo
permettergli di sbagliare perché
l'errore è importante soprattutto per i
giovani l'errore fondamentale permette
di fare esperienza ed è una cosa
fondamentale per l'evoluzione per la
crescita dei ragazzi poi c'è la parte
valoriale ecco quando raccontiamo le
nostre aziende
dobbiamo raccontare quelli che sono i
reali valori quindi se diciamo di
credere nella sostenibilità o nella
trasformazione digitale poi queste cose
dobbiamo farle veramente perché
altrimenti poi le persone se ne
accorgono e allora dicono a con la
solita cosa all'italiana e poi garantire
una qualità della vita adesso i ragazzi
le persone vogliono avere un ottima
qualità della vita e la flessibilità
allo smart working diciamo tutti quelli
che sono i progetti di conciliazione
comunque aiutano a facilitare la vita
delle persone e sono degli strumenti
attrattivi
ok ma allora voi adesso sarete pensando
bene bene antonella matura in pratica
che cosa fai
beh allora io questo concetto dello
spazio l'ho preso forse un po troppo sul
serio perché diciamo la mia idea l'ha
concretizzata in uno spazio fisico che
si chiama galdi village e che è un
edificio che è nato vicino allo
stabilimento produttivo della mia
azienda che però non produce nulla non
produce manufatti non fa prodotti
produce idee è uno spazio che mi piaceva
molto l'idea di a place to feel un luogo
da riempire un luogo da riempire di idee
di emozioni di relazioni di progetti da
condividere insieme da portare avanti
per il futuro perché
visto che adesso ho il privilegio di
poter dare spazio a delle persone
ho voluto che questo spazio fosse uno
spazio che facilitasse la vita delle
persone e le facesse crescere
nell'ottica proprio di sostenere quelli
che sono i valori i concetti di cui vi
ho parlato prima e allora adesso non
voglio perdermi in racconti troppo
dettagliati del del village però magari
vi raccoglie i faccio due esempi perché
è importante insomma per capire che è un
po il centro di formazione di galdi ed è
il luogo nel quale c'è proprio una
stanza dedicata a quelli che sono i
webinar ad esempio a quella che alla
formazione ibrida in presenza ma anche
con la con l'opportunità di avere
persone dall'esterno che si collegano
proprio nell'ottica di inclusività e di
condividere quelli che sono i percorsi e
poi abbiamo un bistrò il bistrot è una
volta si chiamava mensa adesso è
diventato bistrot ed è un diciamo dove
dove le persone fanno passano la pausa
pranzo e io sono molto molto orgogliosa
di vedere che i miei collaboratori a
loro volta sono orgogliosi di evitare le
persone in azienda e di far vedere
l'azienda per cui diciamo per cui
lavorano e poi abbiamo l'area fitness
l'area fitness è nata per perché
comunque abbiamo tanti sportivi in
azienda ma abbiamo anche tanti genitori
e sappiamo che i genitori hanno
difficoltà a dedicare del tempo diciamo
a se stessi
ed è importante diciamo è importante in
qualche modo sostenere il fatto che
possano prendersi cura e quindi il fatto
di riuscire a garantire
l'opportunità di fare esercizio fisico
nelle pause è un obiettivo importante
che avevamo in particolare per le donne
perché sappiamo che le donne comunque
dedicano sempre poco soprattutto le
mamme dedicano poco tempo per per il
loro benessere per la loro forma fisica
l'ultimo corso che stiamo proponendo è
la mindfulness
e noi nel 2021 abbiamo avuto un boom di
nascite quindi un boom di gravidanze di
maternità e qualcuno la frecciatina me
l'ha mandata mi ha detto che volevi
assumere più donne e adesso la sfida
organizzativa come la mettiamo
la mettiamo che voglio ancora assumere
donne soprattutto i ruoli tecnici e di
responsabilità
per questo per questo motivo sosteniamo
il progetto che ha un progetto di
orientamento per le ragazze delle scuole
medie e delle superiori che scelgono
indirizzi umanistici che si chiama gerz
coded better e sono dei laboratori
esperienziali che permettono alle
ragazze che magari non sono mai entrate
in contatto con la tecnologia di
sperimentarsi anche in altre materie e
di provare attraverso dei laboratori
decoding di robotica a a vedere che cosa
significa lavorare in quest'ambito fare
progetti in quest'ambito è la
soddisfazione vedere che qualcuna poi
scopre una passione in un settore che
non avrebbe mai
immaginato di scoprire e io mi ci rivedo
un po in queste ragazze che cambiano
idea e che cambiano ambito perché ci
vuole coraggio a cambiare idea a
cambiare strategia
a cambiare modo di gestire le cose e
allora auguro a queste ragazze di
trovare spazio e poi una volta che
magari l'hanno trovato di trovare spazi
che loro a loro volta trovino spazio
anche per qualcun altro
grazie